[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya aujourd'hui une guerre de la
communication autour du confit ukrainien
on voit bien que tout ne se déroule pas
manifestement comme prévu pour les
russes que le pape l'ukrainien que le
gouvernement ukrainien est extrêmement
courageux et que l'union européenne
prend des sanctions extrêmement forte
nous poursuivons le recensement complet
des avoirs financiers des biens
immobiliers des yachts des véhicules de
luxe qui appartiendrait aux
personnalités russes sous sanctions
européennes
je pense en particulier c'est à ces
sanctions que le
la communauté occidentale on et que j'ai
moi belle aux hommes
l'empiré les mensonges essaie de mettre
en oeuvre entre notre pic tous les
regards se tournent en ce moment même
vers la frontière biélorusse au nord de
l'ukraine où des négociations viennent
de commencer entre délégations russe et
ukrainienne les négociations de minsk y
avait un engagement du gouvernement de
kiev d'organiser une autonomie pour ces
deux régions c'était avant l'occupation
par les russes avant et après dans
minsky avait l'engagement de donner une
autonomie à ces territoires qui ont il
ya une population russe et russophones
et de garder l'enseignement la longue
russe ces choses-là ont été supprimés à
kiev parce qu'elle ait pas de majorité
politique royal estime que et bien vous
disqualifier en en étant un devenu un
va-t-en-guerre estime que vous ne devez
plus être candidat à la présidentielle
écoutez je pense que ségolène royal
comme un certain nombre de responsables
politiques français ne sont pas pu ne
sont pas sortis de la guerre froide j'ai
vu comment malheureusement une classe
politique ukrainienne très corrompu et
très incapable très d'incapables a
laissé filer la chance d'organiser un
statut dans laquelle la minorité russe
pouvait trouver sa place on n'en serait
pas là
quand j'entends effectivement ségolène
royal dire que le problème c'est les
armes américaines en europe je pense
qu'on est totalement à côté de la
réalité d'aujourd'hui l'otan a accru des
tensions en europe l'otan est une
administration dont le premier but était
de perdurer donc on est allé s'inventer
des ennemis que je voyage beaucoup de
français sont très inquiet et
légitimement parce que nous sommes
embarqués dans une aventure qui ne nous
concerne pas et parce que appartenant à
l'union européenne et à l'otan nous
risquons d'être entraîné vers un conflit
que les français ne veulent pas si
l'otan avait été dissoute comme cela
avait été promis aux autorités du pad
soviétique au moment de la de la chute
du mur alors nous n'en serions pas là
prêt qui a fait cette promesse et bien
vous savez très bien que cette fait
cette promesse a été faite ou de hauts
dirigeants hauts dirigeants je veux
absolument souligner la responsabilité
des puissances impérialistes de l'otan
des états unis et puis finalement de la
france dans cette affaire là donc moi si
vous voyez ma ligne de conduite c'est
c'est justement de ne pas faire
confiance pas faire confiance dans ce
gouvernement
confiance c'est aussi dans tel bond de
non
non vous pouvez pas dire ça vous pouvez
pas dire ça parce que je ne peux pas
vous le dire maintenant mais il était ça
a été dit ça a été reconnu par tout le
monde cette guerre elle n'a pas commencé
jeudi dernier ce n'est pas vrai c'est
depuis 2014 qu'elle existe dans le
donbass il y a déjà eu quinze mille 15
mille morts est en réalité ça fait des
décennies et des décennies que les
grandes puissances impérialistes exerce
une pression militaire sur la russie en
avançant avec
sur des positions castex a reçu cet
après midi à matignon les principaux
candidats afin de faire un point sur la
crise parmi les sujets abordés l'accueil
bien sûr des réfugiés d'ukrainiens
nous adressons à l'union européenne en
ce qui concerne une intégration sans
délai de l'ukraine via une nouvelle
procédure spéciale et c'est presque gêné
qu'ils ont tous demandé à pouvoir faire
campagne on en a parlé mais le premier
ministre à donner sa bonne volonté mais
il reste que s'il n'y a pas de campagne
l'élection sera volé aux français